Дитиною, в віці шість років і десь 10 чи 9 місяців
я бачив, як відбирали, віднімали,
витягували з людей...
В моїй хаті прийшли троє
і забрали те, що в нас було.
І я бачу: стоять вози,
на них мішки, із других хат тягнуть мішки,
щось тягнуть, забирають.
І я чую, як люди голосять, кричать.
В повітрі такий страх, така напруга,
люди налякані, бо це вирок: вмирати.
Все було навмисно зроблено.
Хай була у 46-му в нас голодовка,
то був неврожай, засуха була,
тут уже видно: картопля не зійшла.
А це? Дуже великий врожай був.
Забрали ж у нас, все позабирали.
Корову забрали в колгосп. Забрали у нас зерно,
знайшли в коморі, у бочечці в коморі було закопане.
Нема зерна, нема молока – голод.
Ми почали голодувати.
Мати зробила по торбинці через плечі,
і ми пішли з братиком по колосочки.
Ми там і зерна наїмося,
і колосочків принесем додому.
У нас було таке страшенне дитинство.
Дуже було важко і страшно згадати.
Ну що їли? Їли калачики,
їли пасльон збирали, кругом виїдали.
Оці червячки. Мати їх намиє, насушить, нажарить.
Все було лучче,
але головне - молока не було, корови не було.
Ми дуже бідували, дуже голодували.
Ну а була конячка, що мертвих завозила на кладовище,
і ту конячку вкрали молоді хлопці.
Вони зарізали її, попались.
І суд судив їх, принесли вони те м'ясо
на пошту коняки. І люди прибігли, розібрали те м'ясо.
Ми набрали відро кишок,
принесли їх додому, мати вже їх помила, все зробила.
Наварила, насмажила, то нам був то Великдень великий.
Оце ми тих кишок наїлися.
А в Бердянську, в місті не було голоду,
там всі працювали і там видавали пайки.
Батько, що він приносив?
Він хліба не приносив.
Він приносив оцю кільку, хамсу,
ну вона така якась була... вже жмихи.
Оці жмихи - мати робила оладки
і клала прямо на плиті і ми оце їли.
Голод був тільки в селі,
а в селах в ті роки
на Україні жило десь більше 80% населення,
тобто вмирала майже вся Україна, всі села.
Дуже мерли.
Звозили їх в спільну могилу.
Везли і мертвих, і живих.
То я чула так легенду від батьків,
що попав туди живий у ту яму,
то він пооб’їдав вуха мертві
і виліз із тієї ями і, кажуть, дуже довго ще жив, врятувався.
Ми ходили з батьком, збирали жолуді,
але далеко не ходили, ось скраю в лісі,
бо там далі лежали мертві.
Чужі люди лежали прямо незакидані.
Лежали трупи, то я й зараз пам’ятаю ті трупи.
Потім з’явилися чутки,
що десь когось...
Якась жінка з’їла своїх дітей.
Це страшне, що десь там ще когось вбили,
десь впіймали якогось,
хто торгував пиріжками з м’ясом людським.
А мені сказали,
щоб я з двору не виходив, бо тебе з’їдять.
Ну а корову вже нам пригнали,
то десь на весні вже город орала.
Вже нам було легше, батьку підтримку давав колгосп.
А тоді вже пішла на полі і картопелька в городі,
вже й бурячок, вже мати з буряка
червоного чи білого цукрового різала
і варила нам компот.
Вже компот ми з буряків пили,
бо не було більш солодкого нічого.
Уже ми пішли вєсєлєй.
Нам було дуже радісно, що ми
наче вилізли з того багна і з того великого горя.
Голодомор – це було катування.
Це саме звичайне катування.
Людей зламали.
Зламали, бо вони бачили, як вмирають діти.
І ті, хто залишився живий, він все те пережив.
Ті райони, де був голодомор, -
люди дуже відрізняються вже й сьогоднішні
від тих на Західній Україні, де Голодомору не було.
Вони були не під Радянським Союзом.
Зовсім інші люди, вони сміливіші, вони відкритіші.
Було невідомо скільки,
тоді ж заборонено була казати таке.
Тоді було Боже сохрани (говорити - Ред.) за Голодомор...
Бо це ж було забрали куди? У Росію.
То нам роти затуляли.
Як я поїхала оце в музей Голодомору
і на постаменті я побачила книжки.
Я побачила кожанську книжку:
товста, здорова і там написано було 900 чоловік поіменних.
А скільки безіменних? Ми не знаємо, скільки в тій ямі.
Вихід тільки один: пам’ятати про Голодомор,
пам’ятати, хто в цьому винен,
пам’ятати, що всі біди наші українців приходили звідкіля?
З півночі, від росіян.
Я й зараз, коли їм, то кришечку ту бережу.
І залишаю шматочок хліба,
бо це моєму наче братику треба лишити.
Чи матері той шматочок, і зараз.
Я не забула з тих пір,
в мене в душі воно й зараз, наче вчора було.
Мені страшно, мені страшно навіть його й згадувати.
І страшно, і радісно на душі, що зараз є все.
Їж, що хочеш, пий, що хочеш.
Є! Хвалити Бога.
Щоб не трапилося, не дай Боже, щоб не повторилось отаке.